the heart will never fail you now  serving the heart doesn't mean that you  get to have health insurance  serving the heart doesn't mean that you  get to have your 401k and everything  lined up the way that you want it to  when we were on our knees and we just  hadn't gotten the relief and things  hadn't broken through even though we had  been repeatedly serving our hearts and  going through this experience I didn't  have a bank account for four years like  I mean there was like some major [ __ ]  that happened the key is inside the  heart and it's in each one of us because  if we can activate what that natural  expression is that is so beautiful So  Divine so profound and it might not be  seen by anyone it's not about being  famous or having like a big reach it's  about doing what is authentic what is  your way of expressing in the world that  thing that only you can do in the entire  Omniverse